[Music]
hey what's up everyone so in a really
crazy unexpected turn of events last
night there was leaked footage of the
trailer for Captain Marvel now it is
important to note that this is
technically not an official trailer it
was a CGI test at comic-con for brie
Larson but here it is
[Music]
so this is the only real footage that we
have of Captain Marvel it's basically
just her suiting up for omission and I
mentioned this because this clip right
here is the only piece that was shown at
the comic-con CGI test for real arson a
few of you have already messaged me
asking me about other certain trailers
that are out there for her saying that
some of the footage doesn't look real
and you're right some of this footage
that these other trailers have is just
added from some sort of different movie
I've already seen a bunch of kind of
fake trailers combined with this release
that was given the other day but since
they showed this CGI test at a comic-con
and since now it's really circulating on
the Internet and everyone can see it
that means that we're gonna have an
official trailer probably pretty soon
and that's really exciting because
captain Marvel's the big guns right
they are calling Captain Marvel in to
help defeat Thanos after infinity war
I'm super excited for Captain Marvel
because they say it's been rumored that
not only is she gonna have the normal
powers that Captain Marvel has but
she'll also be wearing the quantum bands
in the movie if they introduced the
quantum bands into the movie then that's
a segue for cosmic entities to actually
be in the movie which i think is kind of
what needs to happen after infinity war
so that's it for the trailer hope you
enjoyed it and I hope it makes you even
more excited for Captain Marvel let me
know your thoughts in the comments below
and drop a like and subscribe to my
channel if you want to stay up to date
on Captain Marvel and all things Marvel
and just a quick reminder about our
giveaway for your chance to win a free
speaker system be sure to subscribe to
my channel like this video comment below
with your favorite superhero from Marvel
DC or anywhere else thank you so much
for watching
woof woof
[Music]
you
you